[Music]
and back from death news oh no mommy Wow
submitted by JK news attic the best type
of a dictionary yes yes yes yes gimme
more researchers will begin testing a
stem cell method they hope will bring
the dead back to love no leader dead are
you always e I don't want to be brought
back to life
we're overpopulated like a [ __ ]
I want my grandpa to come back that's
the pregnant lady one more though so we
are over so I didn't want a kid and then
I didn't know didn't and then this guy
right here was like oh it's all David's
fault yeah I told you relieve yourself
of the responsibility really yeah I
that's the responsible adult thing to do
David was like no you guys are good
people good people need to procreate and
people need to make more good people and
I'm like aw David right yeah I love you
was talking about you guys though I
think he was making eye contact and it
is a hundred percent true though because
like there is like this this study
basically people who are dumb or like
lower educated who have stupid opinions
tend to be a lot more duplicitous you
know I mean they tend to procreate a lot
more the people who are more intelligent
are so busy trying to work on the
cortical careers they're not developing
the future leaders of this nation yeah
so what happen is that this one smart
kid is supposed to replace the intellect
of a thousand dumb people but these
people will not procreate it's not
balancing it out so that's the issue
dollar Dumber people are just hotter and
they [ __ ] more I'm all good so they're
coming a lot more you're the future
little soy beans pop it out baby shall
we yeah Toby Stull Reese and that stands
for tortilla and right thanks to Uncle
Joe y'all right I keep forgetting that
I'm like why is this worried and then I
didn't know the gender so I just found a
gender-neutral
gender-neutral name Tories oh that's
gonna be the nickname good Tori Tori
Tori I
is Philadelphia based company called bio
quark and they announced in late 2016
that they believe brain death is not
irreversible they believe they can
reverse bring them oh the dying of
neurons yeah so you know how now the way
across like multiple countries the way
they declare death is when the heart
stops and like in your brain sauce so if
you if you don't have any brain activity
you're considered dead like that's how
they can harvest Orient's is when
someone is declared brain dead because
then they're still able to pump oxygen
into the rest of the organs keeping it
Oregon to live but the person aim is
technically declared dead so this
company they claim that they can reverse
it and they can bring the person back to
life if they receipt if they experience
brain death now they have announced that
they're going to start the stem-cell
method practice on these patients and an
undisclosed country in South America
because their initial e they were going
to start their trials in India but then
India officials found out and they put
stop to it they were like not here go
somewhere else you're not going to come
here and do that handing a guy here
what the hell you together get ahold of
yourself have some decency because want
to die to later who dies it's not
natural in this first stage it's called
first and human neural regeneration and
neuro reanimation both and so they're
saying that it's going to be a non
randomized single group two
proof-of-concept study I don't like it
these are the longest [ __ ]
names for everything yeah so they're
going to be examining individuals aged
15 through 65 that have been declared
brain dead from traumatic brain injury
using MRI scans are going to be
examining these patients and the way
that they they believe that they can
reverse brain death is in three steps so
the first one is they harvest stem cells
from the patient's own blood and then
they inject it back into the patient so
it comes from the patient
yes through stem cells and then it's the
second step is that they inject peptides
into the patient's spinal cord step 3 is
15 days of laser and median nerve
stimulation while monitoring the
patient's using MRI scans and they
believe in that you know what's
interesting Frankenstein
when this happens right somebody is
brain dead they're declared dead and
they come back to life this is going to
give people that that question of is
there an actor Oh God when they come
back and they go dude I can tell you
what heaven is now or even worse this
allows a portal for the demons to now
possess because it's a gateway because
everybody knows that when you go
brain-dead you go to the other side but
then now your body is a vessel a empty
vessel without a soul but when it comes
back a demon's going to slide in and
pretend to be you world domination why
did we let them come into our realm dude
those clusters oh they just a zombies
and then we're gonna go make up all the
time yeah cuz this company has already
stated that they will not be testing on
animals you know they just want to start
testing on human so that's kind of scary
what schedule awesome they going to skip
the animal face how do they get
permission to just go on a human that's
very controversial right now too because
they're saying how are you going to get
consent from these people that are
technically declared dead maybe from the
family members that come back to life
and be like hey I must sue you now
yeah I don't know who what's the family
member
aspects is involved in that I don't know
I would be pissed if they did that [ __ ]
there's those people who are declared
dead and they come back into life all
salty active I want to know how when
your brain dies then that's it like
there's a it causes some sort of damage
in the brain they claim that they can
reverse that that's the damaging I don't
understand it oh yeah I think it's just
the brains not working I think if you
like the private brain of oxygen that's
what I was probably this analogy but I
think this is the brain just died if
they like I felt crazy like I wouldn't
online this if somebody did it to me
let's say I'm like I died now right
today I'm a little too young for it but
if I'm like 90 years old and they
piggyback on
what a [ __ ] I don't like it you know I
think it's pretty cool like yeah if it's
like a situation where it's a really
young person it was like they've gone
too soon and they're just eclair
brain-dead like it's pretty cool to have
this hope for the families know that
hands-on like the laws and the situation
so like if it was like a young guys a
boxer or something right and he gets
knocked in the head so hard to the point
where he's brain dead I think that would
be cool and I think everyone would want
that guy to come back to life you know
to fight identified again or everyone's
a big fan of him or something like that
but I think the concept itself just as a
blanket statement bringing all these
dead people back that is a scary thought
but I feel like there are instances or
it could be pretty beneficial but
skipping the animal face kind of scares
me
mm-hmm usually like just through just
through like an animal it's similar to
humans you get to work out all these
bugs first and then you go to humans but
they're not really straight testing on
humans you're like oh [ __ ] you might are
not scary the organs are like wooden
eastern stop people from getting women
to just say stop bringing back in
everybody that sprained in this poor
little kids I need that hand a very very
expensive operation and a lot of people
are can agree to do this okay like
family members and stuff I would do it
for the sole purpose of someone coming
back to life in saying I remember what
happened and it's like Inception on the
other side it's like this and then
everyone knows now when I die I'm going
to McDonalds oh there's like a movie
about this one cot in McDonald's
remember 8:20 now I never agreed to this
you know straight up those since
McDonald's it hasn't been [ __ ] with
me I haven't even done I don't remember
this clown was I here yeah I don't
remember a boycott because I I actually
got some french fries Wow Joey let my
team down man oh I got the [ __ ]
Nuggets at Wendy's they're not better
than the McDonald's my left something
where'd you get it
oh when we go like a month ago I got it
with bomb as [ __ ] dude are you sure you
weren't just really hungry
well it was itself central and it was 4
a.m. in the morning that's why the only
things are better still oh I haven't
tried it crispier and juicier and Fator
so the ones I had at nighttime they must
been a fresh batch that [ __ ] was crunchy
as all oh yeah so maybe you got a bad
batch maybe could be but they do taste
different the reason one McDonald's
chicken nuggets taste good is because
they had a very specific flavor to it
yeah talking about that crust that it
has is just glorious when it has
frosting sir when your boss all i need's
all delicious oh my god no please come
and sponsor me because McDonald's has
slighted me so many times because they
keep on giving their sponsorship to the
wrong Asian people yep don't cry David
Union okay Wendy when did you gather
back I mean when you don't have the same
type of love back from the ones that you
love so much you start to drift away
hello everybody
if you like the video make sure that you
guys leave us a thumbs up because if not
I'm gonna find you where you live and
I'm gonna hug the [ __ ] out of you
whether you like it or not other than
that you know there's like more videos
of their breath